[Applause]
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to channel
awesomes orbit report your source for
everything pop culture and entertainment
news i'm heather ruse
I'm Brian Porter and this is your news
for Monday September 4th okay first off
happy Labor Day everybody hope
everybody's enjoying a nice day off give
you a little extra time to watch our
show so first news store we got is
Leonardo DiCaprio is tentatively rumored
to be in the front running for the Joker
origin movie and to me that's a little
weird considering the Joker origin movie
supposed to be set with a young Joker
and Leonardo DiCaprio is older than
Jared Leto so I don't really understand
this casting here yeah personally I
really don't think it's actually gonna
happen I think people were like all
right Scorsese is producing it
so DiCaprio yeah yeah he could be a
joker I really honestly don't think this
is gonna happen I think people are just
trying to create hype around the project
interest around the project I just
honestly don't think it's good and I
feel like that's basically DC's game
plan for pretty much all of their movies
nowadays they put out tons of these
rumors they just get all this hype going
and we get people talking about it and
nobody knows what's going on until the
movie actually comes out and that's I
think they're they're kind of formula
for success whether or not it actually
works but I mean yeah Leonardo DiCaprio
as Joe first seems like it could be an
interesting idea but not for a joke
originally yeah I mean he's a good actor
he's got a lot of range but yes agreed
for a joker origins movie if we're going
back to an origin story then it seems
like you want to have a younger actor
portraying the Joker
even though it is supposedly an else
world story they have officially put
that label on it so it won't be the
Joker's origin story that is canon
whatever whatever is canon in the DC EU
nowadays i personally am not on board
with the dover origin movie cuz i feel
that that is the draw of the joker we
don't know his origin we don't know his
motives and i know everybody's gonna say
Killing Joke The Killing Joke well in
The Killing Joke he is said to say you
know if I have to have a past I prefer
to be multiple choice so that isn't
technically canon so again I think there
should be no joke origin movie but I
think rest well just see we'll have to
see what happens with that one
absolutely in other movie news the
rights to the crow has been bought by
Sony so they've been kicking around the
idea of a reboot of the crow for a very
long time there have been some actors
attached the project unattached
reattached new actors attached to it and
now Sony has officially sweep tin and
bought the rights to it and maybe
sometime in the future might be making a
crow reboots I don't know I mean I like
the original they had a lot of like
sequels and such that were pretty awful
and I really don't think it needs to be
addressed again I think the original is
the best and it's one of those movies
that we don't need to reboot I mean I'm
all for reboots on certain characters
certain franchises but there are some
that it's just like really shouldn't
touch and I feel like that the crow is
one of them in respect to Brandon Lee
and it's just I really don't think you
can expand on what we saw in a better
light all right I mean there is some
magic that happened with the first with
the original crow movie that I don't
think they're gonna be able to recapture
like you said especially with respect to
Brandon Lee so supposedly this is
supposed to be a more faithful
adaptation to the graphic novel yeah
that's oh so you know take that with a
grain aslam not that we have any
confirmed dates for any kind of filming
or any casting yes that for this just
that Sony has bought the rights yeah so
we'll see what happens I mean if they
come out with it I'll watch it and you
know hope for the best but I'm not super
super excited about that so when he
doesn't have the best reputation
absolutely not profit from them many
many movies things yeah in TV casting
news Titans has cast another actor I
feel like we've been hitting this every
week so we've got Raven
we've got Starfire and now we have Dick
Grayson he's being played by Brenton the
whites who was in The Giver
Maleficent and you said yes in the
newest Pirates of the Caribbean movie hi
it's the Caribbean 36 I don't know where
we are anymore
um the interesting thing about this
casting though is that Geoff Johns has
said that they have cast Dick Grayson
not Robin not Nightwing but Dick Grayson
and he has also said that this Dick
Grayson has just left Batman
okay so we're really not sure if he's
Robin if he's Nightwing if he's
somewhere in between which actually I
think could be very interesting and a
really interesting character arc to play
out to see how he could become this
character or transition yeah I feel like
that's a really good starting point for
that character going forward and it
tightens and obviously there's no
there's no established Titans so it's
gonna be him trying to you know see all
these other super-powered individuals
trying to get a team together so while
the team is trying to figure themselves
out as a team dynamic and then
themselves you know how their powers fit
in with the world and whatnot it's
really going to be good to see that type
of dynamic mix with the personal dynamic
and how Nightwing or you know Dick
Grayson becomes either Nightwing or
stays Robin and then takes on the role
of leadership so I really am looking
forward to it I like this casting a lot
the guy has a good build he has a look
for Dick Grayson I feel and his acting
chops are great I love them in the giver
yeah I agree tastic definitely think
that this is probably the most exciting
casting news coming out of Titans yeah
very personally so it makes me excited
for the show it's not getting released
until 2019 and on DC streaming service I
don't know how much I want to pay for a
DC streaming service considering most of
what I've seen DC lately has not been
that great other than the CW shows I do
love to fly shows I might give it a shot
you know if I can see it maybe it for a
free you know pilot episode yeah sure it
goes yeah so moving forward let's get us
some book news September 1st the Friday
that just passed was a special day for
Harry Potter fans everywhere it is the
first day of the Hogwarts Mester
September 1st Ave first day of Hogwarts
semester and it was also a very special
day because it is 19 years later
September 1st 2017
is the nineteen years later of the
epilogue from the books and the movie
where you see Harry Potter taking his
son Albus Severus Potter and to the
Train start its first year at Hogwarts
so I think that is just a fantastic just
a full-circle moment for the fans and
for the story we actually you know it is
19 years later and that feels really
good there was a huge in London at the
Kings Cross station there was a huge
event and not only did we have a bunch
of Potterheads there we had Warwick
Davis who plays Professor Flitwick and
Griphook in the seventh and eighth movie
yeah so he was there he's talking a lot
of the fans talking about how this this
Harry Potter fandom has has this
longevity to it 20 years later it was
still going strong right it's pretty
crazy to think how long that this has
really been in like our cultural
landscape Harry Potter has been a part
of both of our lives for so long so
there is some kind of finality almost
with getting it be September 1st 2017 it
is 19 years later and like that I kind
of uh it's now we're going forward into
a time that is you know we don't really
know anything that's going on with as
far as we we kind of knew like a little
bit through what Pottermore and what JK
Rowling is said answering questions
right but now we're in new territory
where after the 19 years later we're
going forward if you do want to count
the Harry Potter and the cursed child
books that's kind of like the Canon I
mean I know it is but some of us don't
want to so this is that so most you
Porter yeah yeah but uh either way it is
it is really awesome and thinking about
it made me very very happy to just just
watch the stuff and watch the footage at
Kings Cross yeah see how happy everybody
was right so we wish Albus Severus a
fantastic first year at Hogwarts this
year absolutely let's go on to some
gaming news destiny to the much awaited
for sequel to destiny is coming out this
upcoming Wednesday September 6 and they
just read just released the live-action
trailer for destiny 2 and it features
cayde-6 voiced by the amazing Nathan
Fillion yes explaining
how the the invasion of the Cabal are
basically taking away everything
birthday cakes you know baseball all the
stuff he's going through a big montage
of all this stuff exploding it gets the
puppies and then one of the guardians in
this talking is to his like puppies know
and he's like Jayde's whoa I'm more of a
cat guy myself but go into this awesome
huge battle live-action battle it looks
amazing and then you see one of the
guardians at the end so at the end say
let's do it for the puppies not any runs
off I relate to that I really that so
absolutely but it was an absolutely
fantastic trailer is really cool to see
cayde-6 the he's a you know a robot type
being and his live-action look was
amazing look very realistic and it was
awesome and I'm super excited for the
game I can't wait to pick it up I'm
gonna be playing a lot online it's gonna
be amazing I can't wait awesome well
that's all for us here let us know in
the comments what you guys are excited
about this week what other new stories
you saw you know let us know how do you
feel about the Leonardo DiCaprio Joker
may be white I don't know where can
people find you on social media
supported on Facebook under a Brian
Porter and Twitter at pork chop 0 to 89
and you can find me on Twitter at
Heather ruse or Instagram at a truce or
twitch.tv slash Heather ruse so for all
of us here we'll see you next week
beam us up
[Applause]
you